[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und marietas lomka guten Abend Tag
der Deutschen Einheit für die einen mag
das nur noch einen willkommener Feiertag
sein für andere ist es nach wie vor
Anlass nachzudenken über dieses
gemeinsame Deutschland die Zeit der
Teilung und die Sporen die sie
hinterlassen hat und für Politik und
Medien ist das natürlich auch immer
wieder Anlass Bilanz zu ziehen wie steht
es zwischen Ost und West 33 Jahre nach
der Wiedervereinigung darüber wie es
wirtschaftlich steht im Vergleich der
alten und neuen Bundesländer wollen wir
gleich mit einer prominenten Ökonomen
reden doch zunächst berichtet Martin
Niesen von der offiziellen Einheitsfeier
die dieses Jahr in Hamburg stattfand
gemeinsam singen geht er zu Ende der 33
Tag der Deutschen Einheit in Hamburg ein
Tag mit vielen nachdenklichen Appellen
an den Gemeinden
am Mittag in der Elbphilharmonie der
Festakt zur Einheitsfeier mit der
versammelten Spitze des Staates und 1300
geladenen Gästen der Präsident des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts hält die
Festrede mahnt und der muntert
gerade in Zeiten epochaler
Herausforderungen kommt es entscheidend
darauf an dass der Staat den Menschen
etwas zutraut und die Menschen sich
selbst auch der Gastgeber und amtierende
Bundesratspräsident appelliert dann
Politik und Volk nicht Populismus und
Polarisierung sondern gemeinsam und
Kooperation sind das Gebot der Stunde
jede und jeder Einzelne sollte sich
fragen ob sie oder er dazu einen Beitrag
leisten kann
so weit dass er Ware
[Musik]
begonnen hatte der Tag mit einem
ökumenischen Gottesdienst im Michel und
einem unerwarteten ersten Redner dem
Klimaforscher motji plativ ich wünsche
mir das von diesem dritten Oktober ein
Signal ausgeht
ein Signal des Aufbruchs die Bewahrung
des Planeten ist ein
Gemeinschaftsprojekt aller Menschen es
gibt keinen Planeten B
auf dem Bürgerfest rund um Alster
Mönckebergstraße und Rathaus tummelten
sich derweil mehrere hunderttausend
Menschen denen mehr oder weniger zum
Feiern war
naja wir haben glaube ich immer noch
einen Unterschied ist jetzt ein Lohn und
Rentenniveau warum ich mein
wirtschaftlich sieht man ja dass der
Osten auf jeden Fall immer noch nicht so
stark ist wieder Westen gibt es diese
ganzen Brüche nach der Wende aber so
insgesamt denke ich mal ist schon ein
ganzes Stück weit zusammengewachsen am
Nachmittag übergab hamburg den
Staffelstab an Mecklenburg-Vorpommern
dass die bundesratspräsidentschaft
übernimmt bis zum nächsten Einheitstag
der heute gehe in der Hansestadt war ein
ausgelassener aber eben auch ein
nachdenklicher
[Musik]
Veronika
zugeschaltet volksprofessoren für
volkswirtschaftslehrer und als Mitglied
im Sachverständigenrat für Wirtschaft
eine der deutschen
Wirtschaftsweisen guten Abend Frau
Professor kann
über die Wirtschaftslage im Osten reden
und da haben sie letztens
interessanterweise gesagt der Osten hat
zunehmend Standortvorteile
ja genau das ist so die
Wirtschaftsleistung ist zwar noch nicht
ganz angeglichen und auch die Löhne und
die Rentenniveaus sind niedriger aber
der Osten hat die Krise besser
überwunden ist besser aus der Krise
gekommen und das sogar trotz der
signifikanten Probleme rund um die
Chemiestandorte die ja in der
Energiekrise viel Thema waren insofern
gibt es Grund zur Hoffnung und auch in
diesem Jahr ist die Vorhersage der
letzten Konjunkturprognosen das
Ostdeutschland leicht weg während
Gesamtdeutschland leicht schrumpft und
das gibt doch durchaus auch Grund zu
Hoffnung worin liegen denn diese
Standortvorteile also der ostbeauftragte
der Bundesregierung Carsten Schneider
hat es mir letztens so formuliert dass
er sagte wenn man eine wirklich große
grüne Wiese braucht und man ein großes
neues Unternehmen anzusiedeln die gibt's
eigentlich so nur noch im Osten
ja so kann man das auch ausdrücken der
Osten hat einfach sehr stark investiert
in Forschung und Entwicklung zum
Beispiel hat Sachsen drei Prozent seines
Bruttoinlandsprodukts ausgegeben für
Forschung und Entwicklung das ist mehr
als doppelt so viel wie andere
Bundesländer und das trägt nun auch
langsam Früchte wir sehen Ansiedlungen
wir sehen auch Ökosysteme für
Technologie Start-ups und das ist
natürlich eine positive Entwicklung und
die großen Ansiedlungen die haben jetzt
auch maßgeblich zum Wachstum des
prognostiziert wird beigetragen insofern
gibt es durchaus viel Hoffnung es gibt
Fachkräfte es gibt die Ausbildung für
die Fachkräfte und es wurde in wenn
investiert in Infrastruktur und eben in
die Forschungsstandorte es gibt
natürlich auch einiges an Subventionen
also dass sie teilweise jetzt eine
schifffabrik im Silicon sexy also in
Sachsen bauen das intern nach Magdeburg
kommt da sind auch viele Milliarden Euro
aus der Staatskasse geflossen
ja genau das ist so aber man muss auch
sehen dass diese Unternehmen natürlich
nicht an diese Standorte gehen würden
wenn die Rahmenbedingungen ansonsten
nicht stimmen würde man kann vielleicht
noch hinzufügen dass die der Standort
Ostdeutschland auch ganz gut geeignet
ist auch aus energiepolitischer Sicht
die Rahmenbedingungen für den Ausbau
erneuerbarer Energien sind besser
natürlich in den eher nördlichen
Regionen aber eben auch durch die Fläche
da gibt es mehr Potenziale und auch
wahrscheinlich doch weniger Widerstände
gegen den Ausbau von Leitungen von
Windkraftanlagen und das sind natürlich
Vorteile von denen man jetzt auch
profitieren kann
aber auch jetzt eben im Bericht gehört
dass es eben ostdeutsche nach wie vor
sagen also die Renten sind immer noch
nicht auf dem gleichen Niveau vielleicht
formal bei der Rentenanpassung da wird
im Osten sogar mehr angepasst aber die
Löhne sind halt nicht so hoch es gibt
weniger eine geringere Eigentumsquote es
fehlt an Führungskräften ostdeutsche
Herkunft in der Wirtschaft wie erklärt
die Ökonomen das
ja genau also es gibt immer noch eine
Anpassung die noch vor uns liegt die
Löhne steigen allerdings stärker als die
Westdeutschen Löhne sind auch zuletzt
stärker gestiegen und auch die Renten
sind stärker gestiegen als die
Westdeutschen Renten ich glaube bei der
Beteiligung gerade der ostdeutschen
entführungspositionen das ist wirklich
eine Herausforderung der sich die
Gesellschaft auch stellen muss ich
glaube hier muss man wirklich auch an
der Wurzel anpacken um wirklich viele
Leute zu ermächtigen und Ihnen die
Möglichkeiten zu geben in
Führungspositionen hineinzuwachsen es
wird ja auch so sein dass gar nicht mehr
so einfach
identifizierbar ist wer ist jetzt aus
dem Osten wer ist aus dem Westen es gibt
ja auch viele ehemalige westdeutsche die
im Osten Leben und umgekehrt aber da
muss noch sehr sehr viel passieren um
tatsächlich zur Gleichberechtigung
hinzukommen und das auch in den
Führungspositionen gespiegelt zu haben
und waren Industrievertreter warnen aber
auch sie und auch Ihre Kolleginnen die
Wirtschaftsweise Monika Schnitzler davor
dass es auch einen Standorte Faktor gibt
der sich wirklich handfest zu
wirtschaftlichen Nachteil entwickeln
kann nämlich wenn sich extremistische
Parteien immer weiter durchsetzen oder
in Ostdeutschland sogar in
regierungsfunktion kommen in die
verhalten wie fern ist das ein wirklich
handfester belegbarer Standortfaktor
ja ich glaube man muss diesen Tag der
Deutschen Einheit auch dazu nutzen
einerseits an die positiven
Entwicklungen zu erinnern und
gleichzeitig klar zu machen der
aufkommende Extremismus die größere
Zustimmung zu extremistischen Parteien
insbesondere zur AFD das ist natürlich
eine Gefahr für den Standort weil viele
politische Positionen in der AFD eben
diese Standortvorteile auch schnell
zunichte machen können gerade die großen
Fabriken die sich ansiedeln gerade die
Start-ups die brauchen viele Mitarbeiter
hochqualifizierte Mitarbeiter die
brauchen auch Zuwanderung aus dem
Ausland die Zuwanderung brauchen wir
nicht nur weil Fachkräftemangel herrscht
sondern auch weil eben durch diese
Diversität ganz neue Impulse und eine
ganz neue Innovationskraft in den Osten
kommt und deswegen ist es ganz wichtig
dass man sich diesen Entwicklungen
entgegenstellt und die Menschen auch
erklärt dass das keine sinnvolle
Entwicklung ist und vor allen Dingen
auch die Chancen vermittelt sagt die
Wirtschaftsweise Veronika Grimm ich
danke für das Gespräch
ich danke Ihnen
nirgendwo hatte man die deutsche Teilung
so vor Augen wie in Berlin und in den
Gebieten entlang der innerdeutschen
Grenze wo mancherorts ja sogar ganze
Dörfer regelrecht durchtrennt worden
waren man war sich so nah und doch so
fern ein Katzensprung nur und zugleich
trennten einen Welten und Todesstreifen
für die benachbarten Gemeinden
Herleshausen in Hessen und Gerstungen in
Thüringen war das so ein Gemeindeteil
von Gerstungen das Dorf lauchrüden lag
sogar mitten in der Sperrzone unter
dauerbewachung und praktisch
abgeschottet von der Außenwelt
bis zur Wiedervereinigung seitdem halten
die beiden Gemeinden eine schöne
Tradition aufrecht jedes Jahr halten
ihre Feuerwehren eine gemeinsame Übung
ab man ist sich wieder nah aber nicht in
allem wie Daniela Sonntag berichtet
es ist nur eine Übung aber eine echte
ost-tradition seit der Wiedervereinigung
immer zum Tag der Deutschen Einheit
ernstfallprobe für die Feuerwehren aus
der Thüringer Gemeinde Gerstungen und
dem hessischen herrleshausen
Kameradschaft wird groß geschrieben und
die Wiedervereinigung ist aber sowas
durch die durch die Decke gegangen dass
es super viel ist zusammengewachsen die
Einheit sehen hier alle an der
ehemaligen Grenze positiv und doch es
war vieles gut an der Wiedervereinigung
aber manches ist vielleicht auch schief
gelaufen und man hat vielleicht auch
ja Biografien gebrochen diese Übernahme
war eigentlich ja nicht nicht von
gleichberechtigten sondern von sage ich
mal der Westen hat den Osten geschluckt
da ist vieles auf der Strecke geblieben
die Brücke der Einheit froh sind die
beiden Bürgermeister über diese
gemeinsame Abkürzung für Bürger und
Rettungsdienste auf beiden Seiten
ähnliche Probleme Bürokratie
Personalmangel Mittelkürzung aber die
politischen Reaktionen der Menschen
unterschiedlich von den beiden Gemeinden
lag die AFD bei der letzten
Bundestagswahl in Thüringen mehr als
doppelt so hoch wie damit umgehen da
sind auch die beiden paar Bürgermeister
uneins aus meiner Sicht ist es so dass
man mit der AFD zusammenarbeiten müsste
und um vielleicht auch gerade zu sehen
können Sie Ihre Argumente überhaupt
halten oder ihre Ziele die sie halten
dass man dann sie auch an Taten messen
kann aber ich habe halt immer die
Befürchtung aus der Geschichte heraus
dass wenn die erstmal einmal den Fuß in
der Tür haben dann auch Überhand
gewinnen können woher kommt es dass
diese politische Teilung bleibt und
anscheinend wächst das Unzufriedenheit
33 Jahre nach der Einheit so
unterschiedliche Ventile findet diese
Bevormundung die die jetzige Regierung
durchführt die hatten wir zu Ortszeiten
und das möchten wir nicht mehr
auf Irland hier Unzufriedenheit Politik
was was in Berlin getrieben wird
also mein Land ist auch nicht mehr
inzwischen das kann ich überhaupt nicht
verstehen aber das ist ja wir haben ja
jetzt Landtagswahl in Hessen der die
Tendenz geht ja da auch hin der eine
oder andere Bürger hat es halt auch
nicht von kleinen auf mitgekriegt dass
er sich selber um sich selber kümmern
muss sondern
ihm ist ja immer alles vorgegeben und
vorgekaut worden und indirekt wird
vermisst wir können eigentlich nur sagen
dass uns das weit nach vorne gebracht
hat dass uns das aus wirklich aus der
Enge und aus diesem Randgebiet
rausgeholt hat und in die Mitte
Deutschlands und in die Mitte der Welt
gebracht hat der Blick auf die Einheit
bei der Thüringer hessischen
Feuerwehrübung sind sie zufrieden alles
nach Plan nächstes Jahr dann ein neuer
Test für den Vereinten Ernstfall
und jetzt weitere Nachrichten des Tages
in Italien hatte seine schlimme Unfall
gegeben ja in Venedig hat sich ein
schweres Bus und Unglücke ereignet nach
den ersten Informationen sollen
mindestens 20 Menschen ums Leben
gekommen sein weitere schwer verletzt
laut den Bürgermeister war der Bus von
einer Brücke auf Bahngleise gestürzt und
fing danach Feuer
am Tag der Deutschen Einheit wird auch
Tag der offenen Moschee begangen
bundesweit haben heute wieder viele
islamische Gotteshäuser ihre Türen für
Interessierte geöffnet in diesem Jahr
beteiligten sich rund 1.000 Moscheen die
Veranstaltung soll auch dazu beitragen
Vorurteile abzubauen nach Angaben der
Deutschen Islamkonferenz Leben in
Deutschland etwa fünfeinhalb Millionen
Muslime
Österreich Polen und Tschechien führen
wieder Kontrollen an der Grenze zur
Slowakei ein ab Mitternacht und zunächst
für zehn Tage begründet wird der Schritt
mit einer steigenden Zahl irreguläre
Migranten und dem Kampf gegen Schleuser
vor knapp einer Woche hatte
bundesinnenministerin Fräser zusätzliche
Kontrollen an den schleuserrouten an den
Grenzen zu Polen und Tschechien
angeordnet
türkische Sicherheitskräfte gehen nach
dem Bombenanschlag in Ankara verstärkt
gegen kurdische Aktivisten vor bei
Razzien in der Türkei wurden laut
Innenministerium hunderte Verdächtige
festgenommen darunter dutzende
mutmaßliche Mitglieder der verbotenen
kurdischen Arbeiterpartei PKK am Sonntag
hatte sich ein Attentäter vor dem
Innenministerium in die Luft gesprengt
ein weiterer Angreifer wurde von der
Polizei erschossen die PKK bekannte sich
zu dem Anschlag
im US-Repräsentantenhaus spielt sich zur
Stunde ein ungewöhnliches politisches
Manöver ab im machkampf innerhalb der
Republikaner ist mehrheitsführer
McCarthy mit einem Abwahlverfahren
konfrontiert auf Antrag eines
Abgeordneten aus den Reihen der
Hardliner in seiner eigenen Partei der
wirft mccasi vor bei den jüngsten
Haushaltsverhandlungen mit den
Demokraten gegen parteiinterne Zusagen
der Republikaner verstoßen zu haben der
Ausgang des abwahlverfahrens gilt als
offen
der spanische König Philippe der sechste
hat den geschäftsführenden
Ministerpräsidenten Petrus Sanchez mit
der Bildung einer neuen Regierung
beauftragt da die Konservativen Wahl
Gewinner im Unterhaus keine Mehrheit
fanden wurde Sanchez die Aufgabe
übertragen für eine Mehrheit benötigt
sanche die Stimmen von separatistischen
Abgeordneten aus Katalonien deren
Forderungen er bisher abgelehnt hat
aus Berg Karabach kommen in diesen Tagen
die letzten flüchtlings-
von diesem Hintergrund entschied sich
Armenien heute zu einem
aufsehenerregenden Schritt es tritt dem
Internationalen Strafgerichtshof bei
jenem Gericht mit Sitz in den Haar dass
ein Haftbefehl gegen Wladimir Putin
erlassen hatte Nina Niebergall berichtet
es sind 60 armenische Abgeordnete die
heute die diplomatische Eskalation
beschließen der Beitritt zum
Internationalen Strafgerichtshof nur
noch Formsache der Schritt eine
deutliche Abkehr von Russland auch wenn
Vladimir war dann Jan der die
Gesetzesvorlage mit vorbereitet hat
nicht von Russland sprechen will nicht
von Putin gegen den wegen mutmaßlicher
Kriegsverbrechen in der Ukraine ein
Haftbefehl läuft
natürlich verstehen wir dass es einen
Haftbefehl gibt aber das steht überhaupt
nicht auf unserer Agenda wir diskutieren
über die Möglichkeit diejenigen zu
Verantwortung zu ziehen die ihn
Aserbaidschan Verbrechen gegen die
Menschlichkeit begangen haben das Thema
hat größte Bedeutung für Armenien wir
können unsere Politik nicht gegen ein
oder zwei Länder aufbauen
Aserbaidschan der Erzfeind mehr als
100.000 Menschen sind mittlerweile aus
Angst vor aserbaidschanischen Soldaten
aus bergkam
russische sogenannte Friedenstruppen
eigentlich in Bergkarabach um die
armenische Bevölkerung zu schützen
verwalten nun deren überstürzte Ausreise
es ist der Sargnagel für die Russisch
armenischen Beziehungen viele Armenier
sind schon seit Monaten wütend das
Moskau sie im Stich lässt
russland hat bewiesen dass es kein
wahrer Verbündeter Armeniens ist sondern
das Gegenteil es verhält sich feindlich
wir erwarten Gerechtigkeit die
Gerechtigkeit muss siegen dann wird
alles gut
doch es ist ein schmaler Grad auch das
wissen Sie hier armenien ist ein kleines
Land wirtschaftlich abhängig von
Russland militärisch sogar in einem
gemeinsamen Verteidigungsbündnis
ich weiß nicht ob es richtig ist im
Internationalen Strafgerichtshof
beizutreten mit Blick auf Russland und
den russischen Präsidenten es ist eine
Bedrohung für unsere Sicherheit
Moskau reagiert verstimmt aus dem Kreml
Worte die ein wenig nach Drogen klingen
dass der Beitritt Armeniens zum
römischen Statut des Internationalen
Strafgerichtshofs aus Sicht der
bilateralen Beziehungen eine gute
Entscheidung ist wir finden das ist eine
falsche Entscheidung ist
Armeniens Abgeordnete haben entschieden
sollte Putin nach Eriwan reisen müsste
er festgenommen werden das enge Bündnis
passé doch ohne russland steht Armenien
sehr allein da es wird sich nach neuen
Partnern umschauen müssen
kommen wir zu etwas erfreulich als heute
verkündet wurde wer den diesjährigen
Nobelpreis für Physik verliehen bekommen
gab es auch in Deutschland Jubel genau
genommen beim Max-Planck-Institut für
Quantenoptik in Garching bei München
eine der Spitzenforscher haben Institut
der Physiker Ferenz Kraus bekommt den
Preis zusammen mit einer französischen
schwedischen Wissenschaftlerin und einem
weiteren Kollegen der in den USA forscht
Kraus gilt als Begründer der sogenannten
Physik und unsere
wissenschaftsredakteurin Christina
Aufgabe übernommen und zu erklären was
das ist
dieser Mann mag sein Metier Tag der
offenen Tür am Max-Planck-Institut für
Quantenoptik ausgerechnet heute ferens
Kraus erklärt Besuchern Artur Sekunden
für Sieg gerade hat ihn der Anruf aus
Stockholm erreicht aber er macht einfach
weiter fast als sei nichts geschehen und
dennoch
ich war ich war absolut überwältigt ich
habe mich gefragt ob ich jetzt Träume
oder oder ob das sozusagen Realität ist
und das frage ich mich ein bisschen
immer noch
ausgezeichnet wird der zusammen mit Pia
agustini und an Willi die schon vor
Jahrzehnten die Grundlagen legten für
die heutige Würdigung
eine große Überraschung nach all den
Jahren hatte ich damit nicht mehr
gerechnet
ich war mehr und mehr fasziniert von
dieser Forschung und man lernt jeden Tag
dazu sogar nach 30 Jahren
es geht um Elektronen sie formen einen
Klebstoff zwischen den Atomen so
entstehen die Moleküle aller lebenden
Organismen
unser ganzes Leben besteht
in der mikroskopischen Welt aus
molekularen Prozessen das heißt
eigentlich jede Vorgang der am Ende
vielleicht zur
zur Entstehung eines eine schweren
Krankheit führen kann jede Vorgang fängt
mit elektronenbewegungen an
[Musik]
Kraus gelang es Prozesse die viel zu
schnell ablaufen um für uns sichtbar zu
sein in Echtzeit zu beobachten er
begründete die artussekunden für Sieg
eine atosikkunde das ist eine Zahl mit
18 Stellen hinter dem Komma die erste
Messung eines so schnellen lichtimpulses
gelang vor mehr als zwei Jahrzehnten sie
war ein Meilenstein seiner Forschung
eine physikalische Meisterleistung aber
ihm geht es um mehr das Ziel wäre es die
Methode soweit zu entwickeln dass man
tatsächlich diese Erkrankung in einem
sehr früheren stadiumstadium 1 2
entdeckt wo wo die Heilungschancen
ungleich besser sind als in einer
späteren Phase
eine einfache Blutprobe mit infrarotlich
zu durchleuchten einen Fingerabdruck der
Moleküle so stellt sich während Kraus
die Vorsorgeuntersuchungen der Zukunft
vor dieser Gedanke treibt ihn an jetzt
erst recht
und jetzt geht es bei dir noch mal
weiter Heinz mit Wirtschaft und mit
Sicherheitsfragen ja die EU-Kommission
arbeitet an einer Strategie für
wirtschaftliche Sicherheit dazu hat sie
heute Pläne vorgestellt für eine
Risikoanalyse sicherheitsrelevanter
Technologiebereiche
welche Gefahren sieht die Kommission da
also einerseits will die EU weniger
abhängig vom Ausland sein beispielsweise
von Rohstoffen andererseits will sie
verhindern dass kritische Technologien
abwandern oder für
Menschenrechtsverletzungen
beispielsweise missbraucht werden dafür
nimmt sie jetzt vier Branchen in den
Blick KI Biotech Quantencomputer und
Halbleiter und führt eine sogenannte
Risikoanalyse durch und danach schlägt
Brüssel dann weitere Schritte vor zum
Beispiel Exporte oder
investitionskontrollen China wird nicht
explizit genannt dennoch wird klar dass
es hier bei auch oder vielleicht sogar
vor allem um China geht für die
EU-Kommission ist das ein Balanceakt
handelsbe Bewegungen mit China sehen
viele Länder skeptisch auch Deutschland
und das EU-Parlament hat heute grünes
Licht gegeben für neue Instrumente bei
handelskonflikten wie stellt sich die EU
da auf bislang ist die EU über die
Welthandelsorganisation gegangen was
meist einen ziemlich langwierigen
Prozess nach sich gezogen hat und mit
dem neuen Instrument kann Brüssel auf
wirtschaftliche Erpressung also
Handelsbeschränkungen oder
wettbewerbsverzerrende Subventionen
schneller und scharfer reagieren
beispielsweise mit Strafzöllen oder mit
dem Verbot bestimmte Produkte zu
verkaufen der globale Handel kämpft mit
immer schärferen Bandagen die EU wie es
scheint will da nicht mehr länger
zusehen vielen Dank
ein Ergebnis aus der Fußball Champions
League am zweiten Spieltag der
Gruppenphase hat Union Berlin am Abend
zwei zu drei gegen Sporting Braga
verloren und für die Fußball EM in
Deutschland im nächsten Jahr hat heute
die erste Verkaufsphase für Tickets
begonnen bis 26 oktober können sich
Interessierte online für die
Eintrittskarten bewerben wenn die
Nachfrage des Angebote übersteigt
entscheidet das Los die Preise liegen
zwischen 30 und 1000 €
nach 18 Tagen geht heute das Oktoberfest
in München zu Ende 7,2 Millionen
Menschen haben laut Bilanz die Wiesen in
diesem Jahr besucht das ist der neue
Rekord und sechseinhalb Millionen Liter
Bier wurden getrunken weniger als beim
Oktoberfest vor der Pandemie 2019 dafür
waren alkoholfreie Getränke umso
beliebter davon wurden mehr als 50% mehr
ausgeschenkt
und jetzt die Wetteraussichten morgen im
Norden wolkig mit einem frischen
Westwind und zeitweise Schauern sonst
freundlich vor allem am Nachmittag und
Richtung Süden größere Wolken Lücken 16
bis 21 Grad in den nächsten Tagen im
Norden weitere Schauer in der Mitte und
im Süden nach lokalem Nebel freundlich
dazu wieder wärmer am Samstag 19 bis 26
Grad
kennen sie Zerbst
möglicherweise nicht die Stadt Zerbst
liegt zwischen Magdeburg und Dessau und
hatte über viele Jahrhunderte eine
ziemlich bewegte Geschichte und eine
weltberühmte Tochter Katharina die Große
stammt aus dem Fürstenhaus Anhalt Zerbst
vom Zerbst aus trat sie 1744 als
14-Jährige Prinzessin ihre Reise nach
Russland an was bekanntlich eine
ziemliche Erfolgsgeschichte wurde also
weniger für den russischen Zaren als für
sie die Stadt Zerbst steht aber auch
noch für eine andere beeindruckende
Erfolgsgeschichte hier residiert der
beste
sportkeglerverein der Welt
davon erzählt uns Andreas weiß
hier wird erste Bundesliga gekegelt
Aufsteiger Markranstädt ein Vorort von
Leipzig in schwarz gegen
rot-weiß-ultra im weltkegelsport die
Halle gut gefüllt man hofft auf einen
Ausrutscher des serienmeisters aus
Sachsen-Anhalt kurze Anlauf und alle
Neune Sportkegeln Klassik das hat nichts
mit Kegelbrüdern zu tun die eine ruhige
Kugel schieben
es ist genauso wie die sonntagsgruppe
die auf dem Bolzplatz oder auf dem
Fußballplatz einfach zusammen ist und
ein Bierchen hebt aber wir befinden uns
hier auf einer Ebene Champions League
erste Bundesliga und das sieht es aus
bei wie bei allen anderen Sportarten am
Akzent hört man es er kommt das Franken
nicht aus Zerbst auch Mannschaftskapitän
Timo Hoffmann reißt zu jedem Spiel ein
paar hundert Kilometer aus Bayreuth an
die Zerbster ein gesamtdeutsches
Erfolgsmodell
jedes Saison beginnt ja bei Null und
jeder versucht uns zu schlagen und
deshalb vielen Jahren und es ist ja
schon alleine Motivation ist immer
wieder zu erreichen immer wieder mit
unterschiedlichen Mannschaften auch ja
und so ist es ja auch in dem Jahr wieder
ja die Konkurrenz wird ist natürlich
schon bestrebt uns zu schlagen aber
unser Ziel ist natürlich an den Titel zu
verteidigen 17 Mal nacheinander
Deutscher Meister zum letzten Mal im
April ausgelassen gefeiert werden alle
Titel und zu Hause in der Zerbster
Kegelhalle ist kaum noch Platz für neue
Pokale zu den 17 gewissen Meister kommen
noch elf Weltpokal und fünf Champions
league-titel Ergebnis einer
kontinuierlichen Aufbauarbeit über fast
25 Jahre die potente Sponsoren überzeugt
trotzdem Profis gibt es in Zerbst nicht
doch die Erfolge ziehen natürlich die
besten deutschen und auch ausländischen
Spieler Richtung Anhalt es hat auch
Veränderungen im Weltverband gegeben und
vor zwei Jahren war es tatsächlich so
man es ist da ist auch etwas eingefahren
gewesen und man hat dann gesagt das ist
das was ich immer noch Wahnsinns super
finde wir wollen wir haben wie Zerbst
Zerbst als Blaupause für die kegelwelt
doch erstmal gilt es den Aufsteiger aus
Markranstädt zu schlagen es ist ein
hartes Stück Arbeit doch nach drei
Stunden ein klares sieben zu eins und
viel Lob vom Gegner
hartes Training gutes Konzept
tollen Verein im Rücken solide Sponsoren
im Rücken dass da quasi auch quasi das
Backup gut unterstützt ja und tolle
Jugendarbeit also ist wirklich in
vorzeige Verein ab morgen wird dann in
Serbien und den Weltpokal gekegelt es
soll der zwölfte für Rot was Zerbst
werden
wir drücken die Daumen hier im Programm
geht es gleich weiter mit der Reportage
Reihe 37 Grad heute mit dem Titel später
Träume neue Welten über Menschen die
auswandern wenn der Ruhestand naht und
um 0 Uhr gibt es dann die nächste heute
Express und uns morgen wieder auf
Wiedersehen
[Musik]